diane stein tu veux faire quoi cette
nuit la même chose que chaque nuit
fabien tenter de conquérir les jeux de
hasard
salut aujourd'hui on va parler des jeux
de hasard des martingales qui sont des
systèmes pour essayer de gagner à des
jeux de hasard
on va aussi parler des méthodes qui
permettent d'essayer de gagner au loto
alors forcément g peu de statistiques et
probabilités mais trois fois rien c'est
juste pour vous illustrer depuis
toujours l'homme veut gagner aux jeux
d'argent mais pas des petites sommes des
grosses sommes en plus ce qui est drôle
d'ailleurs parce que c'est le rêve qui
nourrit sa s'il n'y a pas beaucoup de
chance de gagner une très grosse somme y
aura plus de joueurs que s'il ya
beaucoup plus de chance de gagner une
somme plus raisonnable pour commencer
cette vidéo on va parler des martingales
mais qu'on soit d'accord sur une chose
en aucun cas je vous conseille de jouer
de l'argent à des jeux de hasard comme
dit le proverbe finale c'est toujours le
casino qui est gagnant ceci étant dit
voyant ce qu'on appelle la martingale le
système le plus classique pour essayer
de tromper le hasard le but d'une
martingale c'est de s'optimiser sur un
jeu à 50 50 c'est à dire ou un choix à
50% de chances de gagner face à l'autre
choix qui également 50% de chances de
gagner
en fait c'était très clair dès le départ
vous allez retrouver des applications de
ce système pour la roulette pour des
paris sportifs
alors comment ça se passe et martingale
imaginons que je veuille gagner un euro
dans un système où si je mise
un jeu récupère ainsi je mise 2 je
récupère deux experts comme c'est la
mode donne szpiner on va dire qu'on joue
à la roulette
parce que parce que ça tourne tu as
compris le truc à la roulette si je joue
une couleur c'est à dire rouge ou noir
et que c'est ma couleur qui sort alors
je double la mise ça ressemble à du 50
en vrai c'est pas ça mais on va pas
s'attarder dessus c'est juste pour dire
qu'à le zéro qui rentrent en jeu à la
roulette et le zéro c'est pas une
couleur c'est pas le rouge c'est pas de
noir c'est autre chose encore ce qui
permet déjà un petit peu de biaiser côté
50 50 on fonctionne sur deux règles la
première règle c'est que si je gagne je
dois changer de couleur donc j'encaisse
maingain et si je jouais rouge aux joues
noir et si je perds alors je dois
maintenir cette couleur en doublant la
mise par exemple je joue sur noir un
euro et ses rouges qui sera alors du
coup je vais jouer deux euros mais c'est
encore rouges qui sort alors je joue 4
euros mais c'est encore rouges qui sort
alors je joue 8 euros c'est encore
rouges qui sort je joue 16 euros c'est
noir qui sort alors je récupère ma mise
de 16 et je gagne 16 de plus ces 16 de
plus à couvrir mais perdent donc 8 + 4 +
2 + 1 ça fait quinze plus le 1 euro de
départ que je cherchais à gagner moi
j'ai fait tout ça pour un euro du coup
et c'est vrai que ce système est quand
même pervers au final parce que déjà il
faut
avoir beaucoup beaucoup de fonds avec
soin pour gagner peu c'est le principe
de la martingale laon la fin cinq coups
mais imaginez qu'en visant noir durant
dix coups ce soir rouge et 0 qui sortent
comme ça et que ce soit seulement
dixième couple noir sorte selon la
martingale au 10e couchera 512 euros ce
qui veut dire que sur l'a9 coup d'avant
cumulé j'aurais dépensé 5 111 euros
donc pour gagner un euro au 10e coup il
fallait que j'aie 1023 euros de
liquidités avec moi pour gagner un euro
donc si tu veux gagner 10 euros tu vois
ce qu'il te reste à faire et pour cette
vidéo j'ai pu me faire aider par des
gens qui s'y connaissent à un petit peu
plus que moi en mathématiques et qui ont
vérifié un petit peu les tirages de
sortie des casinos en ligne et bien
n'est pas si rare qu'une couleur sur dix
fois d'affilée même dix fois d'affilée
le zéro et encore trois fois la même
couleur
la plupart des casinos eux maintenant on
des tables limitées c'est à dire qu'à un
moment donné la martingale ne suffira
plus à couvrir les dettes même si vous
aviez de l'argent en illimité pour jouer
mais est ce qu'on peut faire une vidéo
sur les jeux de hasard sans parler du
loto non évidemment que non c'est le jeu
de hasard par excellence pour gagner de
l'argent
c'est à dire que même les gens qui ne
jouent pas au loto ont parfois la
conversation de qu'est ce que je ferais
si je gagne au lot encore aujourd'hui
pour le loto il ya des personnes qui
font un classement pondérée des numéros
annoncé hier qu'ils font des
statistiques numéro par numéro ils font
des probabilités numéro par numéro en
fonction de tous les tirages du pass ils
le font tout seuls avec leurs petits
doigts musclés que pas forcément
nécessaire parce que j'ai cherché et on
retrouve des sites internet où il ya le
classement toutes les semaines les
numéros les plus chauds les numéros les
plus froids les statistiques ou les
probabilités numéro par numéro et donc
après faut choisir son camp est ce qu'on
joue vraiment au hasard est-ce qu'on
joue en fonction des statistiques des
numéros sortis parce qu'on joue en
fonction des probabilités des numéros
qui sont sortis ou est-ce qu'on fait
justement un classement pondéré de tout
ça on peut également utiliser un système
réducteur qui permet de couvrir un
nombre de numéros sur plusieurs grilles
parce qu'après j'ai calculé il ya des
trucs marrants avec le loto par exemple
il faudrait jouer vins gris au loto pour
être sûrs et certains que quel que soit
le tirage on est deux numéros juste et
là on comprend pourquoi c'est si peu
rentable de gagner seulement deux
numéros il s'en dit on va faire les
gains en fonction du nombre de chance
qu'ils ont de remporter le gain c'est
logique
et bien si on le regardait un petit peu
ce nombre de chances c'est un calcul
factorielle ce qui est cool c'est que je
m'aime pas vous demander de le
comprendre
si je prends l'exemple de l'euro
millions le calcul s'écrirait comme ça
parce qu'il ya cinq tirages parmi 50
numéros puis deux tirages parmi 12
ayrault donc on va faire 50 x 49 x 48 x
47 x 46 x 5 x 4 x 3 x 2 x 1c pro-fini
multiplier encore par 12 x 11 x 2 x ce
qui nous donne une chance sur 139
millions huit cent trente huit mille
cent soixante de gagner à l'euro
millions
et là il ya des malins qui existent
pourquoi on se mettrait pas en
regroupement pour jeu toutes les grilles
d'un coup et comme ça apprend partage
pas bête du tout mais complètement
interdit déjà c'est illégal de se
regrouper comme ça a autant pour jouer
au loto individuellement on n'a pas le
droit de jouer toutes les grilles
possible il ya deux euros cinquante la
grille ça nous ferait plus de 350
millions d'euros et même les super
cagnotte elle ne dépasse pas les 350
millions d'euros est ce que je voulais
les mecs qui bossent quand même y
réfléchissent ce qui n'empêche qu'il est
très intéressant de noter les tirages et
d'essayer de faire un classement de
pondérer ou d'essayer de faire des
systèmes réducteur c'est à la fois
ludique et stimulant de toute manière ça
devient un challenge
rosie qu'on pourrait le faire sur des
jeux un peu plus simples où il ya une
chance sur 500 1000 de gagner c'est le
cas du rapido par exemple mais le
problème c'est qu'à chaque fois on tombe
contre mon conseil qu'il est ne jouais
pas d'argent sur des jeux de hasard mais
bon ça reviendrait à dire qu'il faudrait
un loto gratuit
en fait mais ça existe et ça s'appelle
bravo l'auto quand j'ai découvert
l'application dû discuter avec eux pour
réfléchir un partenariat pour sortir
cette vidéo là il ya 48 numéro il faut
en choisir cinq il ya les 12 signes
astrologiques pour le choisir d'autres
ce qui nous donne déjà j'ai fait le
calcul 20 millions de chances en plus de
gagner par rapport à l'euro millions 20
millions de chansons plus une paille
d'autres vraiment la plus cool parce
qu'il n'ya rien à payer rien du tout
c'est financé par les publicités il ya
un tirage tous les jours à 20h45 le
tient je les fais en france par un
huissier français c'est bien est
également une dizaines de méga jackpot
en plus toute l'année à 1 million
d'euros
le meilleur job on se met bien avec un
million d'euros au final ça vous permet
de tester des statistiques des pros bas
des martingales les calculs que vous
voulez vous pouvez noter tous les jours
les tirages pour essayer d'affiner le
vôtre vous pouvez faire avec un pendule
si ça vous amuse
vous pouvez essayer d'autres systèmes du
martingale spécialement pour le loto peu
importe puisque c'est gratuit de le
faire vous mais un lien pour télécharger
bravo l'auto dans la description c'est
pas tous les jours que je fais une vidéo
en partenariat donc vous pouvez vous
dire que c'est cool excès clean merci et
bravo bravo loto ça fait de bravo comme
d'habitude je vous donne la date et
l'heure de la prochaine vidéo ce sera
samedi prochain à onze on le note on
s'organise pour être là mais j'ai le don
du be
vite et puisque je serai un autre
endroit en même temps je serai à la
rochelle ce samedi 24 à 10h45 à la
librairie calligramme pour vous
dédicacer le livre et le 28 juin je
serai à côté de caen à mondeville ce
sera aux cultures âgées plus l'horaire
en tête aller voir sur le site de
cultura ça doit être noté et puis si
vous vous trouvez une question sur l'île
bien dans la description merci d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo j'espère vraiment
qu'elle vous aura plu n'hésitez pas à me
le faire savoir avec le je ne
prononcerai même pas n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà fait
et donc au rendez vous samedi à 11h ciao
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]